the darkness is monster the question is
does it have the key let's hope that it
does
have to beat it to find out
and now I get to be a bandit too
this your judgment and no thief
evil has a price
you think you can be forgiven
Evo has a price
I will fight evil
you think you can be forgiven
what's your most valuable treasure
price
the praise God
huh is this the key is this how you
activate that monuments the theory yeah
it's called crux and supposed to fit
right into the monument and switch it on
somehow but not just for anyone
according to all the tales only those
chosen by God can make them work
it doesn't seem dangerous I think it's
just reacting to your power
but don't tell me you can actually make
it work
well shoot I never thought you'd be able
to do it so you're the real deal we
actually got the crux to do its thing
yes the boss was right as usual you've
got some strange kind of power that the
rest of us just don't here boss I don't
remember being introduced you haven't
but we've been keeping tabs on you ever
since you stepped off the train at the
station but I suppose I should let the
boss explain the rest in person cause
honestly I don't want to get blamed for
spilling the wrong things so does that
mean I'm in I said the boss will explain
in person didn't I you think just anyone
gets in to see her welcome to the gang
you are now officially part of
monoculars
you